[Music]
[Applause]
all right we explain in case you don't
know what I'm talking about this is a
segment where viewers we dare viewers to
try to find mistakes on our show know
what a show does that no we say we dare
you to find us making one tiny mistake
please prove us wrong so far hundreds
and hundreds of challenges over the last
five years not one winner not one
mistake every okay well tonight a fan
with the very provocative screen name
Coco Byrne 4506 which is coincidentally
a cream I've used in the past
thanks thanks he caught a mistake Coco
burned 4506 says it happened recently at
the very top of our show hey Conan Andy
loved the show love you guys
long time watcher but I think I caught
you this time you may think you haven't
made a mistake but check this out that
was crazy I was chewing gum back stairs
and I walked out here what's back stairs
don't you mean backstage I think I
caught you maestro
[Applause]
you guys think he's got me right you
guys think he might have me right
I was I was thank you one person said
never glad my mom's here I love the way
he's staring at us while the TV's going
on in the background yeah that little
creepy you know what I mean
but but still he's a good fan he's a
bright fan clearly he says he caught a
mistake and this kills me because I love
our fans and it pains me to do this but
I'm sorry Coco burn 4506 but it's time
for this coco to burn you you see I do
not thanks really good yeah we had a
third-grader up all night you see I did
not make a mistake I did mean to say I
was chewing gum back stairs
it's a pre-show ritual of mine it's been
going on few years don't believe me
here's some behind-the-scenes footage
from that very night that proves I'm
right okay almost time Gus give me a
piece of gum I'm here by the back stairs
tripping boss there's a favor
I love chewing gum Backstairs
I have been so injured so many times
forgetting that those don't go with it
you've broken your hip about 30 times or
a while
well anyway don't scream like that the
challenge still stands if you're out
there and you think you've sported an
Arab one I show reported at Team Coco
calm / ha ha I found an error we will
sort it out right here on air let's see
if you've got what it takes to make
chunk meat out of the maestro I'm gonna
take a little break when we come back
mini chilled out colors here wasn't that
a great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]